das ist das Trumpfhaus Willkommen im
Stammhaus
[Musik]
riesige Fans
es ist eine Basisbewegung hier und die
Leute kommen hierher, um zu diskutieren, wie sich die Politik
auf ihr tägliches Leben auswirkt
sie treffen Gleichgesinnte und sie
lernen viel voneinander
[Musik]
du  Wissen Sie, es war eine andere Wahl im Jahr
2016,
wir versuchten etwas anderes,
wir waren nach der Obama-Regierung ziemlich verkrüppelt,
und die Wähler suchten nach Veränderungen,
sie mochten Hillary Clinton nicht, und
sie waren sich bei Präsident Trump sicher nicht sicher,
also hatten sie eine Menge
schwierige Entscheidungen zu treffen
und sie kamen fünf- oder
sechsmal zurück und ich musste
sie wirklich davon überzeugen, dass er die beste
Wahl für sie war. Ich denke, er hat es
wirklich hervorragend gemacht. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
ich denke, es gibt viele  von Leuten,
die nicht zugegeben haben, dass sie für ihn stimmen,
und ich denke, sie werden
es tun, wollen es einfach nicht sagen, sie haben Angst,
ja, und das ist, was vorher passiert ist, und
ich denke, es wird passieren
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, dass es ein
Erdrutsch wird, den ich gerne hätte, aber
ich glaube nicht, dass das in Ordnung sein wird, wenn er
wieder gewinnt
ihn zu
bewältigen gut zu
lösen er muss das Gesundheitsproblem lösen
willst du, dass er eine Mauer baut, das
ist etwas, das du absolut
[Musik] hast,
und dieses Mal ist es eine ganz
andere Wahl, diese Leute sind alle
in meiner Zahl  verdreifacht, ähm, es gibt
Enthusiasmus,
sie sind wirklich aufgeregt, für Trump zu stimmen,
sie lieben, was er in vier Jahren getan hat,
und sie haben das Gefühl,
dass sie endlich einen Präsidenten haben, der
für sie arbeitet,
also würde Donald Trump diese
Wahl in einem Erdrutsch gewinnen, sehe ich einen großen
Unterschied
letztes Mal dachte ich immer, er würde
dieses Mal gewinnen, ich weiß es
du